well welcome to the Oscars or as it's
known tonight Cape Fear tonight we are
here to celebrate the movies going to
the movies and what it doing I won't go
to movies hey let's go to the movies the
movies the only place in the world we
can get real imitation butter remember
when there are movie palaces when you go
to the movie theater and see one big
movie now it's all multiplex and
quadruplex the quadruplex is you see one
movie but you're here for but tonight
there's a lot of excitement in this room
because it is the Oscars but we have a
lot of unusual twists and turns and edit
elements that's going to make this
evening very special tonight we also
have the first cartoon ever nominated
not counting Dan Quayle it's
as far as I'm talking about Beauty and
the Beast and not everybody was happy
about the nomination
Fievel did not take it well
took an eraser to his wrists and
Oh d-don't some wite-out but he's okay
check himself into the Betty Boop Clinic
and I think he's going to be okay we
also have the youngest writer director
ever nominated John Singleton
John of course directed and wrote boys
in the hood the David Duke story and
also
this is the air that two people went on
a mad spree across the country shooting
from the hip creating havoc acting
irresponsibly getting in trouble with
the law
with little regard for right or wrong
but Jerry Brown and Bill Clinton
couldn't be here tonight
an Oliver Stone could win his third Best
Director award some say he's paranoid
but his next movie is entitled the men
who shot Liberty valance and
how about Bugsy Bugsy gets ten
nominations and go ahead ten nominations
go
and when odd twisters Ben Kingsley who's
nominated for Best Supporting Actor he
won the Best Actor Oscar of course for
Gandhi and nominated for now playing
Meyer Lansky it's great to say think
about it's interesting Gandhi and Lansky
two men with a vision and neither ate
pork it's sudden I love this band travel
with me and of course it was a big year
for hit star Warren Beatty in an unusual
year first he did press and then he
became a father then he got married and
today is his birthday and I remember
when people just used to take out trade
ads and business was great despite you
want to think ahead think think
and business was great despite a
terrible recession that's hit everybody
take a great studio like Orion a few
years back Orion released platoon it
wins Best Picture
Amadeus Best Picture last year they
released Dances with Wolves it wins Best
Picture this year Silence of the Lambs
nominated for Best Picture and they
can't afford to have another hit but
there's good news and bad news the good
news is Orion was just purchased and the
bad news is it was bought by the House
of Representatives the first movie is a
sequel to backdraft is called overdraft
and who talked about other people's
money now I know what you're saying
you're saying to yourself looking at me
he's any taller no you're saying
in the back I'm not Joel gray
what I know what you're saying you're
saying where's that production number we
haven't had an opening production of we
had a wonderful piece of film but
where's that traditional Oscar number
well folks we don't have one tonight
usually I well good night you know
that's the traditional medley with all
the names of the nominated pictures all
put into one kind of crummy kinda song
well relax you won't hear one tonight
tonight you will not hear
ask Russ who will win the nominee is the
best picture our here's a beauty who's
read most everything from Julia Phillips
to Stephen King the pista used to be a
prince
his hair could use a comb and rinse what
a crazy pair but damn
just movable painting from Dizzy's mom
they laugh like us they walk like us
sometimes even talk like us it could
make you saw such actors
are out of a job
The Silence of the Lambs when they are
gone
a booyah base of cheeks and necks and
all look inside my pots
Vladdy and see
a guy who looks a lot like Chef Boyardee
back much money to buy Oh buzz buzz buzz
II don't ride that mega scam wasn't
Freddie don't feel so bad it could have
been Atlantic City
buzz buzz buzz II they don't call me
buddy my name is Benjamin you can call
me Benny to do call me Benjamin you can
call me mr. thigo you can call me a cab
but just doesn't have to call me money
I'll kill you buzz buzz buzz II don't
cry
the nomination
Hey
three shots in the plaza
whodunnit mr. stone this CIA or Homer
Simpson the FBI or Vic Damone just who
were the villain
the Mafia or PTA Connie Chung or Connie
Francis everyone's in JFK Mel Torme
today Doris Day JFK
don't tell me not to make this film up a
- if someone takes a flop it's me and
not you
I've simply got to make the film the
prince of time
I'll bring this book to the screen guess
who will play The Winston
I'll tell Nick Nolte stand there tight
on my legs mouth and half $7
on the shelf did this film directed self
a mr. Oscar here
this little gold guy
is going away
let me Silence of the Lambs
Oh JFK
Oh Monty
prince of time
beast and ride
votes are in